[Music]
what is your current perspective on say
synthetic options for
psychedelic compounds in the sense that
i found an older interview where you
were interviewed by
nailed magazine
and
there was a bit of a discussion about
you know synthetic freeze-dried
ayahuasca and you mentioned how
it feel free to revise this but how you
felt that it's it may be psychedelic but
it's not ayahuasca because the ayahuasca
experience begins when you taste it and
the purging is potentially a feature and
not a bug and
i'd just be curious to know let's say in
the case of ayahuasca
what do you think some of the most
viable solutions might be to
avoiding over harvesting
and endangering these various plant
species is the
synthetic route you know creating
pharmawaska alternatives
viable attractive
unappealing
ill-fated what's what's your perspective
i think we have to look at all all
viable solutions
for example
psilocybins psilocybin mushrooms
don't really have that issue
i mean they're not endangered right they
can be grown by megatons so
so we're not going to run out of
psilocybin and maybe if we want to go
with natural psychedelics maybe we
should emphasize
those there is a lot of global interest
in psilocybin
and ayahuasca is endangered and and
peyote certainly is endangered and
things like ebola are in danger the
verge of extinction it's on the verge of
extinction and i think part of the
solution is
number one i think the community the
psychedelic community to the degree that
there is one
really has to step up and be responsible
and i i think that the community
should seek consensus for example peyote
is a good example the community
like these decrim movements that are
happening across the country and in
other countries and so on in general i'm
in favor of them
but the indigenous people have asked
don't decriminalize peyote
let it be our thing well i disagree with
not
decriminalizing it because fundamentally
i think no no plan no organism
should be criminalized i think the very
idea is is repulsive to me but that said
the community can say
let's not criminalize it but let's
protect it and let's
develop a community
consensus that okay we'll just
put peyote behind defense we'll say it's
the indigenous people's thing we will
not encourage on that we'll respect that
and we'll avoid
using peyote
some of these other things watchuma for
example watchuma is a good source it's
not endangered yet it's much more
abundant it's easier to grow
that's a good alternative
we're at a point with wachuma where we
can
use it responsibly if we don't then it
too may become endangered eventually
ayahuasca is a very tricky one
i think that pharmawask is fine but it's
not ayahuasca it may have uses and
that's
it's a different drug it's it's
completely different and i have nothing
against synthetics you know i think
synthetics have their place and
like i like to tell people synthetics
are
they're made by all natural organic
chemists right so they come from nature
ultimately
yeah but
what i would like to see happen if if it
could is developing a
you know over time developing
relationships with indigenous
communities
to produce
medicines like ayahuasca but not
encourage people to go to south america
to take ayahuasca
encourage these communities to produce
them and
and take the medicine to the people
rather than people to the medicine
develop ways that are legal
to export them
to north america europe and so on and
through decrim establish centers where
people can come
and have these psychedelic experiences
that are legal and safe and well
structured and all that
and
give benefits
back to the people who produce it who
grow it economically
benefits but kind of avoid the
disruption of the culture that happens
when all these rich gringos come down
there
to take ayahuasca and i mean i'm guilty
i've
organized lots of ayahuasca retreats
i mean i've seen tremendous benefits for
people that come to those retreats
but i've kind of evolved in my view of
it whether that is a actually a good
thing
yeah it is and it isn't and that's why
decrim is important but i think decrim
has got to be
very uh
thoughtful
and and clear in in its approach to this
and say well you know we're not going to
encroach on things like iboga
and ayahuasca
or or do it in this way bring bring the
medicines north rather than the people
south
and that will transform communities as
well both in both places so that's kind
of this is not something that's going to
happen
next week or next year this will take a
decade or more and it depends on how the
laws can be
can be changed
yeah i i would something simple about
this
there's nothing simple
you